Kyllä tuo Trumpi on sitten mukava pellehermanniku.
Se järjestää meidänkin elämän niin jännittävästi.
Nyt ei tiedätä, tulooko sota vai seiketuk. Kyllä jännittää.
Tällaisella puhelulla aloitettiin tämän viikon Kansanradio.
Kiitos ensimmäiselle soittajalle.
Tervetuloa taas ohjelman mukaan ja matkaan.
Nuo Yhdysvaltaen presidentin suunnitteemat tullimaksut ovat pitäneet huolen siitä,
että meidän vastaja ei ole päässyt pahemmin lepäilemään.
Tämän viikon jakso on toteutu yhteistyössä.
Olemme toimittaneet puolituntisen yhdessä niin,
että kollegani Lasse Olkunuor teki hyvän pohjatyön,
ja minä, Lauri Koivisto, viimeistelin ohjelman.
Maailmanpolitiikka ei ole ainoa aihe, mikä herättää tunteita jostain ihmetyksen ja suuttumuksen välimaastosta.
Samaa on ajoittanut tämän viikon varrella myös muun muassa pysäköinin valvontafirmat, euroviisukarsinnat ja valkoposkihanhien suojelu.
Mutta nyt, vielä hetkeksi katse Yhdysvaltojen suuntaan.
Trumppi käyttäytyy ku häyynen kakara, kun se ei saa haluamaansa tikkukaramelliä.
Oulusta, miksi tuota?
Ei olleet tuosta uhkauksesta ja kiristyksestä tuolle Trumpille mitään lakia,
kun eikö sitä muualla osuoneet, jos saa voisi tuomita vaikka lankia? Kiitos.
No, täälapa on yks toisinaa ajattelija tältä kainnoosta.
Kun tuossa joki aika sitten jäättiin näitä noopeleitä,
niin omasta mielestään ihan tärikkiä ehdokashan jäisitteki ilma.
No, eihän hänellä käitännössä ollut pieni päikkä etelitystä tulla valituksiva,
eipähän se ite sitä kyllä ymmärtänyt.
Ehdottaisinkin, että seuraavaa vuotta varten perustettaisiin
vain kerran jäyttävä narsismin noopele.
Tähän kategoriaan olisi todella luonnollisesti vain yksi riittävän valovoimainen erdokas.
Jakotilaisuuteen yleiseksi tulisi valita tarkasti se henkilöjoukko,
joka ei missään nimessä sanoisi yhtä poikittaista sanaa,
vaan olisi mahdollisimman myötäsukainen.
Jossa tällainen menettelysäsi juhlakalun entistäkin itse riittoisammaksi
ja iloselle miele, saattaisi olla suotuisa vaikutustipa maailman rauhan kannatta.
Lauri, täällä toisessa päässä terve päivän puheaa ei ollut
nämä Trumpin tietyille EU-maille määräämätölle lisätullit,
kun ei hyväksytä sitä, että herra haluaa sen Grölani ottaa vaikka väkisin,
niin mun edotus onkin se, että aletaan hengailee Kiinan kanssa.
Venäläisiä emme ollenkö venäläiseksihan ollen?
Tulla, olkaamme siis suomalaisia, mutta olkaamme myös kiinalaisten kavereita.
Eihän tässä kohta sitä Trumpia saa muuta aihosoihin,
kun aletaan koko EU tasolla, niin hengailee pelkästään Kiinan kanssa,
niin johan alkaa herra miettii, et jaa, mitäs käy.
Se paitsi toinen asia tässä, mikä on suuri pelko,
niin jos tää maailman tilanne nyt taas tällaisena jatkuu,
niin en yhtään ihmettelisi, että se Trumpi vetää stään jäämurtaja tilauksikin kokonaan pois,
ja keksii siihen jotain muuta.
Mutta, aika näyttää ei muutaku kaikille kansanrainen kuulijoille jaksamista.
Moi.
Sellainen ehdotus kuultiin siinä.
Seuraavaksi on luvassa lisää ehdotuksia,
nämä tosin liittyvät Yhdysvaltaen presidenttiin vähän äskeistä vähemmän.
Ennen puheluita yks sähköposti, jossa lukee näin.
Pankeille pitäis löytyä kuria.
Onhan se selviö, että kun kansa antaa kuukausittain ilmaisi rahansa, palkan ja eläkkeen,
pankille niin pankki vastaa niistä.
Sitä vastuuta ei poista mikään, edes pankin keksimä oma sääntö.
Pitää säätää selvä laki, jossa pankki on täydellisesti vastuussa asiakkaan rahoista.
Poliitikot herätkää.
Näin sanoihin päätti sähköpostinsa niimerkki, vastuuta vaativa.
Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio@yle.fi.
No, inkku Oulusta soittelee, terve.
No, terve edys.
Temmosesta asioesta soittelee ku tommosesta V-alpusesta kiro-sanasta.
Eikö ihmiset tajua vai eikö ne välitä siitä, että saa alun perin.
Virkka nii nii naisen sokupoli eli.
Ja kuitenki sitä käytetään nii yleisesti, että.
Jos sua tympäsee tai muuta nii, siinä on monta sanaa, joita voi käyttää.
Keljuttaa, kenputtaa, ärsyttää, risoo, panni, ja vaikka mitä muuta.
Olenki kysymässä, et mitkä on ne vaihtoehtoiset sanat, mutta siinähän niitä tuli.
Ne on niitä verpejä, ja sitten voi sanoa, että voi änkereinen, jos keljuttaa,
että näihä sitä lasteohjelmassakin kerran sanota timun sitä.
Änkereinen on hyvä.
Tai mitä tahansa muuta, mutta ei tuota.
Se sana särähtää eniten, korva.
Tehdääkö jopa mielumminin, että korvataan se jollain toisella kiro-sanalla, jos pitää?
Joo, jos on pakko, niin mielummin, nii.
Koska musta vähän tuntuu, että kun ihminen, ihmisen pitää päästäessä kirosella pihalle,
niin sen pitää olla tunteltaa hyvin voimakas sen sanan,
ja siihen ei ehkä sitten änkereinen, välttämättä auta.
Joo, nii, voi olla, mutta sitäkin voi varmaan opetella.
Nii, nii, totta, totta, joo, joo, joo, joo, hyvin moni asia on kyllä opettelusta kiinni, olet oikeassa.
Eli, mikä tahansa muu sana, paitsi Vellä alkava?
Joo, jos joku telkkarissa vaikka käyttää tommoista V-austa sanaa, niin mä pää heti telkkarin kiinni,
ja samoin, jos mä luen kirjaa, jossa on tämmösiä sanoja, niin mä lopetan sen lukemis, ihan periaatteesta.
Selkeät säännöt.
No nii, hyvä.
Minä kiitän, ku soititte.
No nii, kiitot.
Moi.
Hitpa.
Etelokohjan maalta, eläkeläinen Jussi, soittelee kansanradioon.
Suomen ulkopolitiikassa näkyy kaksi henkilöä, jotka esiintyvät maailmalla omituisesti, käyttäen liian pientä Pukukokoa,
joka on mielestäni tasavallan presidentti Alexander Stubilla ja äidin pikkupoikamaisesti käyttivällä Pääministeri Orpolla.
Kumpikin käyttää liian pientä Pukua, että heidän ei ole helppoa liikkuua edes siellä puhun sisällä,
ja mielestäni tämä ei ole ihan fiksua, noin näyttävässä ja toimessa, missä he sitten ovatkin,
ja pitääkö tehdä kansalaiskeräys, että saadaan näille henkilölle sopivat vaatetukset erustukseen.
Tietenkin sitten se suurin asia, mitä olen tässä miettinyt eläkeläisenä,
ja pienituloisia pitäisi Suomen eduskunnan kansanedustajia siellä valvoa,
että kansalaiset voivat hyvin, eikä hoitaa sitä asiaa, että Suomen hyvätuloisevat voivat hyvin.
Parempaa tulovaisuutta kaikille, ja uskoa tulovaisuuteen.
No, se on mu huono tätä isolta kuljeta tervee.
Aiku, se tuli tuossa mieleen valvata eläkeläistä sootteella sinne tästä valtion veloista.
Se pitäis maksaa pois, ja kaikki tätä hoitaa, sit taas asiat oikee hyviä.
No, tämä on kuulee simuloitu jo.
Se on promaniadiktaattori 81, pistää säästökurin päälle, valtiovelkaa hoidetaan pois.
Seuraaksena oli se, että elintarvikeet, perusterveydenhuolto, sähköt, lämmitykset, kaikki romahti.
Tämän seurauksena, se otses ku muijensa kanssa, vuonna 90, ei luodit rintaa.
Onko se sitten semmoinen toimiva järjestelmä, näiden mielestä, johtaa tämmösiä,
onko valmiita tämmöisen säästötoimen pitäisiä laikkaa?
Ei muuta, hyvää, hyvää, hyvää, kevää jatkoja, tervettä velan maksua.
Lissu täällä, hiiri ja myyrä ongelma, ripottele siliä ja valkopitturia, nurkkiin ja oven pieliin, usea monta kerran.
Ja toinen ongelma, muurahais ongelma, ripottele kanelia, kun muurahaiset häityvät, kerää kanelit murkkiin, saa pian taas uudelleen ripotella.
Ja kaneli toimii vielä tosi hyvin, no eipä tässä sitten muuta, kiitos, hei hei.
Kansanradiotervehdys.
Juu, täällä on vanha mummu.
Ja, mitäpä kuuluu tänä?
No, kiitos, oikeastaan, aika hyvin, mulla on hirveän paljon ystäviä, täytyy sanoa.
No, se on hyvä juttu.
Mutta mitä ne on? Ne on lintuja.
Okei.
Joo, joo, mutta yks, mistä mä en tykkää, niin, mulla on yks harakka pariskunta.
Ja ne kuuluu niiden ruokkien todella paljon.
No, se ei ollut oikeastaan siitä, ku me nyt soilti.
Mutta, no, mä kuulin sellaista, että Englannissa, mikä minusta oli ihan järkevää, ne ei enää saa mainostaa pizzoja ennen kielo yhdeksän illalla.
Joo, sinne, siellä, siellä on tulossa televisioradio mainontakielto, että ikään kuin lasten katselu aikana, niin roskarua mainostaminen olisi kielletty.
Aivan, ja niin pitäis olla täälläkin.
Okei.
Sen takia, kun lapset liho, ja sitä, mitä mulla niinku surestaa, nää nuoret äidit ei osa laittaa arkiruokaa. Niin, lenkistä.
Vois laittaa keiton, ja sen kans ruisleetää, eiks niin?
Ja, sanota, kinkkukilsaus, niitä noin pakkaisesta saa semmoisia perunoita ja sipuleita, laittaa yks pussi, sitä, ja kinkkua.
Niinku arkipäivää, mitä sinä ehkä oot saanut lapsena kanssa.
Joo.
Mutta, mä äidit ei osaa laittaa tällaista yksikertaisella ruokkaa.
Sitähän mä haluis semmoinen TV-ohjelma, missä laitetaan ihan, ihan tuommista arkiruokaa.
Semmosta kaipaa televisioon.
Joo, eikä me, kyllä mä kattelin nyt Helsingin Sanomis, kyllä ne kokii, toisaa laittaa ruokkaa.
Mutta, siinähän on kymmene eri mausteita ja kaikkia, ei, no, sanotaan, ehkä enää nuoret äidillä ei oo Helsingin Sanomakaan.
Mutta, siinä on niin paljon erilaisia mausteita, kyllä se tulee hyväksi.
Mutta, ihan mä kaipaan tuommista arkiruokaa.
Se taitaa olla itsellä kanssa jonkunlaista soppaa alkavalla viikolla ruokalistalla, ku tuosta nyt puhuttiin, niin paljon, niin nälkä tulee.
Nii, nii, tällaista mä nyt halusin.
Joo, totta kai.
Oli mun sydämällä se läinä.
Joo, enemmän perus arkiruokaa, minä kiitän, minä kiitän, ku soitit tänne, ei muuta ku hyvää talven viettää.
No kiitos, Sammoi.
Kiitos paljon.
Joo, moi.
Hei.
Ku Englannissa on tullut jo tammikuun kuudes päivä voimaan roskaruan osittainen mainostuskielto.
Eli aamu puoli kuudesta, ilta yhdeksään ei saa televisiossa näyttää epäterveellisten elitarvikkeiden mainoksia, sillä pyritään siis ehkäisemään lasten lihavuutta.
Mutta nyt takaisin kotimaan asioihin.
Minä ihmettelen sitä Millie veikkausta.
Huijaako se veikkaustoimisto ihmisiä?
Kukaa ei koskaan voita?
Osaako joku kertoo, että mitä se oikee on?
Moikka.
Jeesuksen syntymästä on raamatu pyhästä sanasta, että hän synnytti esikuisesta pojan, kapaloo hänet ja panii seimeen, koska heille ei ollut sijaa meadosta.
Ei, Jeesus oo missä kirkossa syntynyt, niinku sitä yritettää nykykansalle todistaa.
Pyhä sana se todistaa sen, että se on seimeenkapaillutuna ja se siinä eläinsuojassa syntynyt.
Tätä on tottuus, eikä mikkää kirkku.
Nykytää viennä, että Jeesuksen syntymäkirkossa sattuu sitä, sun tätä.
Tää on totta.
Ei muuta, ei.
Miksi tämä valkoposkihanhu, hanhi, pelleily saa jatkua, maksetaan kolme miljoonaa euroja korvauksia, eikö tälle valkoposkihanne sotkivat Helsinkiä joka paikani?
Eikö tälle pelleilytty loppo, eikö tämäkin raha pitäis käyttää?
Telvioiden hoito, vanahosto hoito ja muuhun tärkiä, eikä tuommoisen?
Ni eikö tämä viher pesuu tästä maasta lopu?
Tämä on sairasta, tämä on erittäin sairasta.
Ei muuta, kiitoksia, hei.
Tässä vähän pohdiskelin.
Niksiköhän näihin edustusjuttuihin?
Valitaan sen perusteella.
Kuinka vaikea jonkun elämä on ollut?
Onko tää ehdokkuus niiku vaan hyvitystä, jostai huonosta sohtarosta?
Vai mistä on kysymys?
Musiikilla?
Ei kai näissäkään eurovinkumisissa ole mitään osaa, eikä arpaa?
Enkä tarkoita vaan tätä vuosta.
Viime vuonna valittiin se, joka uskaltaa olla vähimmistä vaatteisella käyttäytyä irstaimmin.
Mitä tästä maailmanmenosta pitäis ajatella?
Tuntuu, ku suomalaiset olis taantuneet kymmenial vuosia ikävuosistaan taaksepäin.
Aikuiset päättää ton ku teinejä, vaulajat vinkuja, kitisee ku lapset.
Ehkä vaution pitäis alkaa maksaa, meille harvoille vanhanaikasille jotain sopeutumisrahaa,
että me selvittäisii tästä suuresta murroksesta, joka on isommissakin puheessa jo mainittu.
Hasarroida tervehdys.Tervehdys, täällä on Jouko Helsingistä.
Mistä päin Helsinkiä soittelee Jouko?
Jätkä Saaresta.
Jätkä Saaresta? Mitä tänään suunnuntaina?
No täällä soitellen vaan mun ystävän puolesta, kun hän on maksanut tällaisen parkkisakon vahingossa kaksi kertaa.
Ja tuota, hän on yrittänyt karhuta sitä rahaa takaisin, kun sähköpostille ja viesteillä eivät vastaa viesteihin eikä sähköpostiin eikä palauta tätä rahaa, kuutakymmentä euroa.
Okei, eivät vastaa mihinkään yhteydenottoihin?
Ei mihinkään yhteydenottoa vastaa. Minun mielestä se on tärkeätä, että pitääkö tässä tehdä sellainen niikun niskavuoren hetaita, ei kun ulosotto.
Ja varmaankaan tällä firmalla ei sitten ole mitään toimipistettä, jossa voisi käydä?
Ei, ei, näe mistään mitään toimipistettä.
Okei, oot kattonut kumminkin.
Kyllä.
Se varmaan kannattaa myös kuluttajaneuvontaa ottaa yhteys.
No hän on ottanutkin sinne neuvontaa yhteyttä, mutta eikä oikein osaa mitään vielä ihmeelistä sanoa.
Sieltäkään ei osattu mitään.
No ei, ne mitään ihmeelistä ois sanoa, että pitääkö mennä kärälimään?
Siiis tässä oikeasti ollaan tilanteessa, että ei vain yksinkertaisesti firmasta kukaan soistu vastaamaan eikä rahoja palauteta.
Ei, tahköpostiin eikä viesteihin vastata.
Häkiseltään voisi kuvitella, että toi ei pidemmän päälle oo mitenkään fiksua toimintaa, koska kyllähän se jossain vaiheessa ylittää uutiskynnyksen, jos tuolla tavalla toimitaan, mutta…
Kyllä.
Mä oon mielenkiintoista kuulla, että kuinka paljon ihmisillä on vastaavanlaisia kokemuksia, jos…
Aivan.
Ja, mä en tiedä, onko tää henkilö ainoa, mikä on tehnyt tällaista, mutta aina niiko oma rahaa, kun laittaa tuplana jonkun maksun, ni sitä on hirveä vaikea saada takaisin.
Tyleensäkin.
Selvä, kiitos.
Kiitos paljon, päivä jatot.
Joo, kiitos, hei.
Tähän kohtaan pari kuuntelijaviestiä, jotka on lähetetty kansaradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Ei, sinä, joka etsit kaveria esimerkiksi kahville ja lenkille, kysy paikkakuntasi kulttuuritoimelta, onko kyseisellä paikkakunnalla kulttuurikaveritoimintaa.
Myös seurakunnan diakonilta voit kysyä ystävätoiminnasta, samoin kuin Suomen Punanristillä voi olla ystävätoimintaa paikkakunnalla.
Tämän kommentin oli lähettä nymerkki "ystävä, kaveri". Toisen kuuntelijaviesti se lukee seuraavasti:
Haluan antaa kiitokseselle nishenkilölle, joka puhui kuuntelijan ja auttajan roolin uupumisesta.
Minun isäni, sotien veteraani, sanoi sellaista ihmistä, jolle mikään ei kelvanut, että semmoinen ihminen ei tiedä piereekö se vai paskooko.
Jos siis kuuntelet ja annat hyviä konkreettisia neuvoja asioiden ratkaisemiseksi, niin tämmöiset ihmiset väistävät vastuun, vetoamalla milloin mihinkin, kaikki pitäisi tehdä heidän eteen, kuin manulle illallinen.
Ja jos lopetat neuomisen ja kuuntelun, todettuasi kaiken vaivan valuvan kuin vesihanhen selästä, niin sitten olet paha, julma ihminen.
Ystävyys ei ole vain yksipuolista ottamista ystävyyteen vedoten, vaan se on myös antamista.
Joten se sanonta, että hyvä tulee moninkertaisena takaisin, ei todellakaan pidä paikkaansa vaativien valittajien kanssa.
Neuvoni on, että kannattaa miettiä, mitä rakkauden kaksoiskäsky käytännössä tarkoittaa.
Meille kansanradioon, kirjoitti näin niymerkki, tarttisko kattoa peiliin?
Edelisen ohelman aiheita kommentoivista viesteistä siirrytään viime aikojen yhteen isoimmista uutisessa tässä maassa.
Hei kansanradio, tässä on naisporukalla jälleen kerran mietitty, että mitä me voitais tehdä niille tahmatassu, käpälöiville ukkomiehille,
Ja nyt tällä kertaa siellä eduskunnassa, että niihän se on, totuus, että se on ainoa hauta, missä nainen saa olla rauhassa.
Voi.
Taas nää kansanedustajat on töppäily, ja töppäilevät jatkossakin.
Eiks niiden töppäilijoiden kanssa tarttis tähän niin, ettei valita niitä uudestaan?
Toinen juttu tuli mieleen, ku tää Ano Turtianne lähti sinne Venäjä.
Ja lähti mun mielestä jotain maksuja pakoon taimiks, känylä lähtikään se, ja ei vähän eduskunnalle velkaa.
Eiks voitais pistää ne muutkin töppäilijät, varsinkin se muster töppäilee useimmin, sinne Venäjälle.
Palikohan siitä pitäis maksaa, että saatais me menemään sinne?
Eipä tässä muuta tällä kertaa.
Ihmettelin tätä Yleisradion aamuohjelmaa, täällä kun tästä häirinnästä on tehty niin valtavaa juttu.
Ihan ku tää olis ykkösasia Suomesta.
Miten tää voi mennä tällaiseks, tää Suomen touhu?
Voi hyvä ihme, ku meillä on niin kovat asiat täällä, mitkä meidän pitäis saa selvitettyä.
Suomen talouden nämä asiat olis ykkösasia, ja niitä pitäis pohtia, ja niitä ottaa tänne.
Eipä tässä oo mitään muuta, kiitos, hei.
Siinä ei enää muuta.
Nyt onkin hyvä siirtyä, nimerkki, selkäni on kunnossa, viestin pariin.
Hän on puolestaan huolissaan meidän suomaisten liiallista pokkuroinnista.
Viestissä lukee seuraavasti.
Tuleeko Suomesta koskaan itsenäistä?
Sitä on vaikea uskoa, sillä olemme aina kumarrelleet johonkin suuntaan.
Olemme suorastaan ammattilaisia kumartelemaan, olemaan diplomaattisia, antamaan periksi, ja ennen kaikkea pitämään suuverkki pienemmällä.
Ruotsiin kuuluessamme olimme lojaaleja Ruotsille, sen jälkeen tulikin aika opetella oikein syvään kumartamiseen idän suuntaan.
Ja ehdottomasti suu piti pitää supussa, ettei Kremlissä vihastuttaisi, ja saattaisipa pahimmillaan olla Siberian matka edessä.
No sitten tuli aika kumarrella Euroopan unionii päin, ja nyt viimeisimpänä Amerikan suuntaan.
Ja taas on pidettävä suu supussa, vaikka takapihalla jysähtäisi pommi.
No, toivon, että suomalaisten selkäliakset olisivat kunnossa, vai siksikö meillä on kansansairautena huono selkä?
Näin todettiin viestissä, joka oli lähdetty kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Mutta ei tämä, mahdollisen kumartelun aiheuttama selkäkipu, ole maan ainoa ongelma.
Se selviää viesteistä, jotka kohta kuullaan.
Ennen puheluita, vielä ohjelmamme yhteystietoja.
Kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postia voi lähettää osoitteeseen:
Kansanradio, PL, 79, 000, 24, Yleisradio.
Ja puhelinnumero on: 08, 00, 154, 64.
Ja puhelu on soittajalle maksuton.
Kelro 12:30 alkaen, tuossa numeroso vastaa, ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Ja, meillä voi lähteä myös WhatsApp-sovelluksen kautta, ääni sekä tekstimuotoisia viestejä.
Whatsapp-numero on: 0, 4, 4, 5, 5, 1, 5, 4, 6, 4.
Moi, Suomessa on nyt Euroopan synkin työttömyys.
Elikkä Suomi johtaa tätä tilastoa.
No, sitten, Suomi ottaa nyt ulkomaanvelkaa kaikkein eniten, mitä ikinä on otettu.
Kiitos Orpolle ja Purralle.
Se asian ydin, nykkoon on olympialaiset tulos Helmikuussa.
Mä hedotankin, et järistetää tämmöset niinku valtioiden, hallitusten väliset olympialaiset, että kuka surkeiten pärjää, ni se voittaa.
Ja mä olen sata varma, mä lyön koko pienen omaisuuteni siitä pantiks, että Suomi voittaa sen.
Kut, kaikki mittarit on punasella.
Kaikki on punasella, nyt mittarit.
Nyt mä, tota, noi, tällä hetkellä hankii just Ranskan kansalaisuutta, ihan tämmöses maas voi kuka.
Normaali ihminen enää elää, kyllä tää on järkyttävää käytöstä.
Kiitos Orpolle ja Purralle.
Tuule täällä päivää.
Tuota mä tuosta vanhosten hoidosta, että kun niitä sinne kotiin yritetää hoitaa semmoisia, jotka eivät todellakaan enää pärjää siellä.
Siinä ei oo mitään järkeä, että siellä hoitaja menee sinne pitkiä matkoja, ajelee eri paikkoihin, että hoitajan aika menee siinä autossa istuessa.
Ja sitten tämä nettihomma, että nyt laitetaan nettihoitaja, siellä jossakin netin ääressi, ja sitten niille vasukseille, jotka eivät osaa käyttää niitä nettejä ja robotteja, mitä sinne tehdään.
Et miksi ihmeessä ei voida tehdä semmoisia hoitokoteja? Itseasiassa niitä on olemassa, monessa kunnossa on tyhjillään hyviä kiinteistöjä, johonka voisi nämä vanhukset tuoda.
Ja siellä oli se hoitaja, ja se hoitaisi siinä läheillä, eikä netin kautta niitä. Ei mitään muuta, kiitos.
Lippis, Ylöjärveltä, tää talouden hoito ja yhteiskunnassa nii, ollaan vähän niinku hakoteillä asioista ihan täysiin.
Nytkin huudetaan kotitalouken kuluttamin, no kotitalouks vois kuluttaa enempi, mutta työlisyyk ei nouse sillä myhtää mihintää.
Joku nyt ravintoloissa ja huviteiltoissa ja muissa käy ja semmoisille työlistää ja tuottaa rahaa, muttei sillä mikään työlisyys mihkään nousee.
Ja kyllä tässä nyt taas ollaan ihan hakoteillä.
Ja samoin enää vero kävenyt, et ei näitä tuu yhtään mitää työpaikkoja Suomelle.
Aika sen tiesi jo kyllä etukäteen, että humpuukia touhutaan siinäkin.
Ja meidän pitäis saada nyt vientiteollisuus, Ylö.
Papelivientiä ja huitutlövyjä, näitä vähän edempi saada marmalle, Eurooppaa vaan menenää.
Ja kaikki koneteollisuus, laivateelakaalle, edempi töitä saada, ja
Kyllä tässä nyt ollaan kotitalouksena, huutetaan niinkuin jotain kaikkia hyntipukkeja, kun ne nyt pitää rahojansa pankista miljardikalpailla seisomassa.
Ei niillä mitään työlisyyttä Suomee saada, vaikka ni sieltä kulutettas ponsti.
No päivää, kaikille kansanradion viisailet tietäville.
Kattokaapa netistä South Parkin jaksovuodelta 2009.
Siinä Suomi pommitetaan maan tasalle.
Tätä se NATO kusetus tietää.
Etä hei vaan, toivoo satusetä.
Minä ajattelin kysyä semmoista toisiltaki, kun tuota, minun mielestä tuota juhlanmokan maku on muuttunut huonompaan suuntaan.
Makuun estyroissa joku vika, kun tuota, tämmönen juttu tuli tossa miele.
Tämmönen juttu tuli tossa miele.
Okei, moi.
Jakson loppuun on luvassa vielä toivotuksia ja ehdotuksia.
Enen viimeisiä puheluita, minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää.
Tämän jakson vankan perustan teki kollegani Lasse Olkunuora.
Minä, Lauri Koivisto, viimeistelin ohelman julkaisukuntoon.
Nyt on aika kiittää ja kumartaa.
Kansanradio, jälleen viikon päästä.
On tämmönen pitkäaikainen ollut tämmönen idea, niin tämmöisestä paalijärjestelmän Suomessa, niin täydellinen remon ehdotus.
Okei, iso muutos, kannat tulla.
Nämä kaudet, niin pitäs niinku rajoittaa sillain, että niinku residentin kaudet, että saaks eräkkäistä ja pistä, koko ilija.
Kaikkinin, tota, nää luottamat tehtävät.
Ja.
Siten tämmöisen, niin, päälekkäisyydet, että samaan aikaan ei voi ni, tota, kaiken maailman tehtäviä olla, kun päälikkä.
Valtuustot ja muut.
Sitten me olemme laittaneet tällainen, että nämä kaudet pitää istua sitten loppuun saakka.
Vaikka hampaa tirvee.
Nii, ei lähdetä mihinkään, mihinkään, tota, konsultihommi silla kesken kaikkea.
Ei, ei.
Kun on valittu, niin sitten pitää istuakaan.
Sitten lisäksi on tämmöinen, että maailmalla, niin, tota, on tämmöinen ihan tavallista, että kun sä mokaat, niin sä eroat välittämästi tehtävästä, eikä mitään meriselityksiä.
No, Riso, ni, ku, Suomessa, niin, tota, näitä selityksiä sitten, ni, ku, löytyy maailman pahppiisaa.
Suomessa on myös hyvin suosittua se, että ku tulee töpeksittyä todella pahasti, niin sanotaan vaan, että käsi pystyy virheen merkiks, ja sit se jää siihen.
Joo, nime oma, että erottava, ja sitten tämmöinen, että, tällä se, ni, ku, tää on ihan naurettava, ja typerä, ja tällä, tänne ilse halvera, että, niin, minä kalnaan poliittisen vastu, tai tarkoita, että minä en oo mistään vastu.
Sitten vielä, jos tämä ikä rajaa, minusta ni semmoinen tolkuline ikä rajani on kullekki, niin tota, kyllä mä laittani sinne viiskymmentää, viiskymmentää, viis vuotta, niin ylä ikä rajaa.
Johokki roti, että, ei tämmöisiä 6, 7, 80-vuotiaita enää.
Onko sinulla päällimmäisenä tunteena se, että valta-asemassa olevat siis keskittyy täysin, vaan siihen, että miten he voivat hyötyä siitä valta-asemasta?
Siin siihen, että Paolo velisevat.
Kyllä, kyllä, tää on juuri tämmöistä, että ni, tota, ja sitten tehtävät, että sulle mulle, sulle mulle.
Nii.
Ni, minä oon tässä perään kuulutaan niinku äänestäjälle ni semmoista kuluttajasuojaa.
Hän ei oo minkäänlaista kuluttajasuojaa, että ni.
Äänestäjälle kuluttajasuoja, joo.
Kyllä.
Hei, minä kiitän todella paljon, kun soitit.
Kiitos tästä puhelusta.
Jes.
Samoin kiitos, hei, samoin.
Jes, moi.
Hei, hei.
No moi, se oo mua mumu tässä.
Ajatteli, vaanko, tuo posti lopettaa noita, lopettaa noita työntekijöjen virkoja, nii.
Ei varmaa ens jouluna kannata ollenkaan niiko joulupostia lähetellä.
Mulleki kesti kuukauen, ku tuli tuosta Keski-Suomesta tähän Oulun korkeudelle, nii rataa varsi, rataa mennee tuossa kuitenki koko ajan, ni.
E, tää ei muuta ku talaven köllykkää vaa, ei ta saa muuta ku vilttiää päälle, jos pakkanen tullee, hei parannas.
Kuuntelin tuossa ootisiani, lasten liikkumisestani.
Se ehtivi mitä luulla, sillä eduskunnossa tehtii semmoinen laki, että lapset ei tarvii kävellä koulun, ku taksi kyytivää rappusilta koulun vihaja kantaa sisälle, ja ei tarvii nää lapset kävellä ollenkaan, eikä liikku.
Nyt sitä haukotellaan ja ihmetellään, miten on liikkuminen vähentylläni. Kahtoisivat vain peilini, siltä kahtoo se syy vastaa.
Jotta, minkä tahtaa lapset lopettamaan kävelemisen, eikä oo oppineet juoksemankkaa ennen. Tätä mieltä minä oon. Heippa.
Markojärven päästä hei, minusta ihmiskunnan puurimpia ukkia ovat nyt, ja lähitulevaisuudesta, ilmastonmuutosta ja luontopato, jotka purentavat vaajentuneen ihmispopulaation mahdollisuuksia pärjätä, koska resurssia ei ole tätä iakkaa.
Situelvaisuudessa odottaa uusi ukka. Tekoälyä hyödyntävät humanoidirobotit, jotka sopivat mitoitukkeltaan korvaamaan ihmisen, ilman, että täytyy rakentaa tuotantolinjoja uudestaan.
Kun robottien hinta tikkuu noin kymmeneen tuhanteen dollariin, selimme on menetetty. Maiden verokertymistä tuloverojen osuus on noin kolmekymmentä protentia. Robottien työstä tulisi periää globaalia tuotantoveroa. Muuten näiden yhteisvaikutus on turmiotti.
Vain tehtailijoita tarvitaan, sekä kourallisia ihmistä. Roboteille perehdytetty osaaminen siirtyy napin painellustella vaikka tuhanalle uudelle. Mitä me muut sitten teemme?
Piitos, tää robotti jo kuuntelijanne.
Nyt kun Hectorista on tehty autioraamaan, niin Hector Mikko alatalosta kannattaisi tehdä samantyydyneen ohjelmaa.
Heippa, täältä Itä-Suomesta tämmönen senior nainen soittelee. En sano itseeni mummoksi, koska haluan elää jokaisen päivä ja nauttia siitä.
Valitustahan riittää, sitähän meillä on, mutta tuota, eikös nämä oo annettu meille elämän semmoseksi ponnistuslaudaksi?
Nihen täytyy vaan napakasti tarttuu asia kerrallaan, ja ruvetaan niitä selvittämään. Muuten, muuten, muuten siitä kehittyy justiisa se iänikuinen murhe, että ei saa, ei päivällä rauhaa, ei yöllä rauhaa.
En väheksy kenenkään murheita, en missään tapauksessa. Tietysti, nyt kun on koko maailma vähän myllimmäli, niin se tuntuu, että kaikki on niin kauhean vaikeisti.
Minäkin täällä voisin kertoa loputtommin tälläkin hetkellä, mikä mulla on täällä murheita. Ei pelää netti, ei pelää televisio, ei.
Meillä on täällä Itä-Suimessa, minä voin saanut, tää on Ilomatsin kunta. Ja on kaiken näköistä, kelit on huonut tänne, ei aina pääse minnekään liikumaan, minulla ei oo autokin piti hävittää, kun ei oo ajokorttijaku.
Ja tuota, nii edelleen, nii edelleen, mut ei tässä mitää. Kyllä nyt kohta tulloa haasteita, pitäis mennä verikokkeelle, ja pitäis mennä sinne tänne, kun odottaa mulla pikku hiljaa polven operointi.
Ja sekin, luultavasti, on nyt sitten jossakin. Onko se sitten Savolina Lapperanta? Mutta minä en otan näistä murheita, en missään tapauksissa kiitän, että pysyn vielä jaloillani ja toimin.
Mutta tuota, elämähän on annettu elettäväksi, ja haasteita kohden mennään, niistä voi saada joskus jopa ihan hyvään olon tunteen, kun ne voittaa. Asia kerrallaan.
Kaikille erittää hyvää, odotallamme kevättä, nyt täälläkin on jo lämpimän puolella, katolta valuu, lumeet on mentävä niitä tönimää rappuja edestä pois, että pääsee siitä eteenpäin.
Ihanaa, ihanaa, ihanaa elämää, joka ikiselle suomalaiselle, ja toivotaan, että tämä maailman tilanne rauhoittuu, että ihmisten päättäjien kallot rauhoittuu, ja se hyrrääminen loppuu. Kiitos, kiitos, hei, hei.
Kiitos.